unsere mutter sind zimmer gekommen sagte
dass die deutschen ins land
einmarschiert sind wir dachten dass sie
uns sofort umbringen würden
in der nacht kraft ist dann stark an der
tür mein vater ging hin vor ihm standen
drei ungarische polizisten in forderten
ihn auf das haus zu verlassen
dann schrieben sie raus aus der wohnung
die gendarmen schubst meinen vater auf
den boden und nahmen ihm die schlüssel
ab die kinder fing an zu malen
er drehte sich um mit tränen in den
augen und sagte nein nicht selbst stark
bald kommt die zeit wo wir alle
zurückkehren werden
aber wir sind nie wieder zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
israel jerusalem 74 jahre später die
frau die diese zeilen schrieb lebt seit
1949 in der heiligen stadt ihr name ist
in die sirene müller geboren und
aufgewachsen im damals ungarischen
galanter cindy ist 91 jahre alt eine
überlebende des holocaust
und sie ist im besitz eines
einzigartigen dokument 54 tagebuchseiten
aus dem jahre 1944 auf denen sie als
junges mädchen ihr schicksal und das
ihrer familie aufgeschrieben hat cindy
ist 14 jahre alt als sie mit ihren
eltern und geschwistern von den nazis
deportiert wird zunächst nach auschwitz
birkenau dann in ein arbeitslager ins
niederschlesische peterswald dort
schreibt sie heimlich und unter
lebensgefahr auf laufkarten der
waffenfabrik karl diehl ihre
schrecklichen erlebnisse auf
[Musik]
jahrzehnte hütete in die sorgsam ihre
erinnerungen
erst jetzt ist sie bereit ihre
geschichte und die des tagebuchs der
welt zu erzählen habe ich gearbeitet
diese sind die ergebnisse sind
erschütternd und verstörend wie alle
geschichten der opfer des holocaust
[Musik]
ich wundere mich nur wie ich das alles
schreiben konnte eigentlich war das gar
nicht möglich
es war so gefährlich dort und trotzdem
habe ich geschrieben habe ich es nur
gemacht
sie lebt mit ihrer familie in galanter
einer kleinstadt in ungarn
ihr schicksal und das hunderttausend
anderer ungarischer juden beginnt am 19
märz 1944 mit dem einmarsch der
wehrmacht auszug aus der wochenschau
rentner und irgendwer verständigung in
ungarn ein
[Musik]
mit der operation margarete will hitler
verhindern dass sich ungarn den
alliierten anschließt im gefolge der
deutschen truppen 1 200 mann starke
sondereinsatzkommando unter der leitung
des ss- obersturmbannführer adolf
eichmann
er soll so hitler die judenfrage in
ungarn bereinigen über die menschen aus
gelangte bricht das unheil am 20 april
ein
zusammen mit ungarischen gendarmen
rollen ss-angehörige auf lkw durch die
straßen der stadt
in den tagen darauf plündern sie die
jüdischen geschäfte und eigenen deren
besitzer und treiben die menschen aus
ihren häusern
auch die ähren walz schien dies familie
müssen ihren weinhandl schließen ihr
heim verlassen
alle juden müssen einen gelben stern
tragen
es ist der beginn eines alptraums den
zsc in die von diesem moment an in ihrem
tagebuch beginnt festzuhalten
verzweifelt notiert die 14-jährige wir
packen
jeder hat etwas in der hand beeilung
beeilung es ist bereits alles raus aus
der wohnung
grafisch noch mal herein und schaue mich
um ich kann es nicht ertragen und
verlassen die wohnung wieder
die türkei klar zu hören die schlüssel
im schloss
ein stück papier wird darauf geklebt und
abgestempelt ich drehe mich um und die
tür ist für immer verschlossen
sie wurde abgeschlossen wenn wir verjagt
von dem ort die mein vater kauft da
besteht meines herzens wurde gebrochen
vielleicht haben unsere eltern damals
gewusst wohin will gebracht werden
sollten
aber wir ahnten natürlich nicht dass sie
uns umbringen wollten
ende mai treiben soldaten der ss
gemeinsam mit ungarischen polizisten
hunderte jüdische familien vor den
bahnhof von galanter die verzweifelten
und ahnungslosen menschen kommen aus den
umliegenden städten und dörfern
das wenige hab und gut was sie mitnehmen
durften tragen sie am leib und in
koffern
[Musik]
schnell kamen am güterbahnhof an wo
bereit die viehwaggons auf uns warteten
und wenn es nur das gewesen wäre
erstmals mussten wir aber durch die
leibesvisitation erst dann werden wir
erfahren was wir mitnehmen dürfen
wir laden den wagen ab montagmorgen 9
uhr
ich sitze auf dem gepäck es war ein hart
gekochtes ei und warte auf die
durchführung
es war schrecklich
als werden die reihe kommen ist unser
gepäck zum waggon für die durchsuchung
tragen
ich bin nervös es wird wohl noch
weggenommen von den wenigen
die frauen wissen reicht die männer nach
links zur leibesvisitationen eine kleine
kabine ein teil des gepäcks kommt in dem
waggon
der rest wird weggeworfen ich möchte die
sachen zurück an als antwort werfen sie
sie mir ins gesicht
es tue nicht wie wir bekommen die sachen
jedoch nicht zurück
wir sind fertig
[Musik]
zu diesem zeitpunkt erreicht die
massenhafte deportation der jüdischen
bevölkerung ungarns ihren höhepunkt
adolf eichmann leiter des judenreferats
im reichssicherheitshauptamt hatte sich
zum ziel gesetzt fast 800.000 von den
nazis erfasste juden zu töten
auf akribisch geführten listen stellen
die mörder die zahl der menschen wie
transportgut zusammen
in den folgenden monaten werden so
hunderttausende mit den todes zügen in
die vernichtungslager gebracht
ziel des genannter zugs ein
zwischenlager in ayrshire sammelpunkt
für den weitertransport nach auschwitz
birkenau in die und ihre eltern die
schwester nicky und dori und die zwei
brüder ruby und barry werden mit den
anderen in den waggon gepfercht der
beginn einer unerträglichen tortur
45 das ist unsere anzahl
wir steigen ein wir haben wasser im
eimer für die fahrt vorbereitet und
viertel nach fünf werden die waggons
geschlossen
ich konnte nur durch vier kleine fenster
rein
drinnen sieht es bereits wirklich so aus
wie ein gefängnis mithäftling wir sind
im zug wie tiere gehalten worden
so schreibe ich das im tagebuch aber
nicht mehr waren die tiere
meiner meinung nach waren es die
menschen die das mit uns gemacht haben
[Musik]
es werden namen gerufen an jeder fragt
wer wo ist wir fragen die anderen wir
unsere oma ist wieder ein rock
dazu pfeift und fährt los die männer bis
der ganze waggon meint meine liebe
mutter schaut auf meine schwester yeti
und ruft laut ihr geht es nicht gut
alle herauf zu beten und suchen nach
essig oder franzbranntwein endlich
finden sie es hier die wir damit
eingerieben und es geht ihr sofort
besser
sie wird zur wagentür geführt damit sie
besser luft bekommt die leute bieten
weiter dann ein lautes klirren und die
tür wird geöffnet
frische luft kommt hinein dann leuchtet
uns einen taschenlampen entgegen
es sind deutsche soldaten die erste
etappe für die verzweifelten menschen
endet am verladebahnhof von ashley cole
war
hier hat die ss ein provisorisches lager
in eine ziegelfabrik errichtet es ist
die warte station für über 4.000
menschen vor dem weitertransport
cindy und ihre familie müssen auf dem
boden einer baracke schlafen
dort schreibt das junge mädchen weiter
an seinem tagebuch
die situation verschlechtert sich
dramatisch
[Musik]
ich wache vom vogelgezwitscher auf ich
habe meine augen problem ich ach ja ich
weiß schon ich bin in der ziegelfabrik
in esche kuhbier ich strenge mich und
stehe auf von dem unbequemen liegeplatz
erst jetzt wird es richtig ungemütlich
so sehr tun mir der rücken und die hände
weh das gepäck bündelt drückte meinen
rücken in der nacht ich muss mich nicht
anziehen weil ich meine kleidung
geschlafen habe fühle mich waschen aber
es gibt kein wasser
das ist der erste tag in einer
ziegelfabrik es ist dienstag die sonne
schaut neugierig zwischen den wolken
heraus er selbst sie so etwas noch nie
gesehen hat so viele frauen mädchen
männer und jungen einfach zusammen
überlegt mit halb geöffneten augen
schaut man sich um als ob man es nicht
glauben könnte dass man es wirklich
selbst ist wie schön wäre es wenn mir
ist alles nur träumen würden aber nein
so etwas sollte man auch nicht träumen
schließlich erteilt die ss den befehl
zur weiterfahrt am 12 juni setzt sich
der erste transport mit 2899 menschen in
bewegung
zehn.de und ihre familie sind dabei
ein zweiter transport wird drei tage
später abfahren dann mit 1980 menschen
noch ahnt niemand welches unvorstellbare
grauen noch folgen wird
[Musik]
nachdem sie uns in den zug getrieben
haben mussten wir uns auf den boden
quetschen
es gab keinen platz 75 menschen saßen in
einem waggon der bekamen keine luft wir
konnten kaum atmen
die fenster waren so klein gerade mal 30
zentimeter breit und mit eisenstäben
vergitterten mit wollten sie verhindern
dass wir aus den fenstern flüchten
können
von da ab konnte ich auch nicht mehr im
zug weiter schreiben
ich habe dann alle zettel aus meinem
tagebuch gerissen und sie so
zusammengeknüllt und versteckt die
unterbricht zunächst ihre aufzeichnungen
die zettel hütet sie wie einen schatz
versteckt und der ihren kleidern
wenig später wird sie den inhalt auf die
laufkarten der waffenfabrik übertragen
darunter sind auch ihre traumatischen
erinnerungen aus auschwitz birkenau als
junges mädchen erschien die nicht dass
sie mit den karten ein stück dunkelste
deutsche geschichte dokumentiert hat
heute gut 74 jahre später ist jede
einzelne tagebuch zeile ein wichtiges
zeugnis den millionenfachen mord an der
jüdischen bevölkerung nicht in
vergessenheit geraten zu lassen
ich höre dass manche leute den holocaust
leugnen und das was damals passiert ist
dann koche ich vermute hier in meinem
tagebuch ist alles beschrieben
es ist geschehen und ich tue alles was
sie meine kraft steht damit die menschen
es erfahren und nicht vergessen nicht
nur die deutschen auch die juden selbst
[Musik]
es dämmert als wir die letzte station
ungarns erreichen
warschau wir hören dass die vier monate
alte tochter von einer freundin und ein
anderer bekannter gestorben sind
sie werden aus dem zug gebracht die arme
mutter sie kann nicht mal bei der
beerdigung ihres eigenen babys dabei
sein
sie würden erfahren wo es begraben ist
wir verlassen einen bahnhof nach dem
anderen
es ist abend ich muss auf die toilette
es geht aber nicht
es gibt nur einen topf das wasser wird
immer weniger
man kann sich nicht hinlegen
zwei müssen immer stehen wenn man liegen
möchte gott sei dank gibt es nur wenige
kinder in dem waggon
sie waren es wird gedrängelt und
geschimpft
ich laufe ein auf dem knie von mama der
zug hält an so ein geschrei und
durcheinander dass sie von draußen ruhe
riefen und dann die tür hatten
mein vater versuchte die sache zu
erklären
die tür öffnete sich und dann dort
offiziell steht dort und fragt er das
vorhanden war
der offizier nimmt die waffe von seiner
schulter und will eine frau erschießen
ein lautes geschrei zu hören wir
schreien alle vor angst auf die bitte
von meinem vater hat dass sie doch nicht
erschossen
vierzehnter juni 1944 nur noch wenige
kilometer trennen die züge mit den
leidenden menschen von auschwitz
birkenau seit zwei jahren dient der
komplex als vernichtungslager das fabrik
mäßige morgen an juden sinti und roma
und anderen häftlingen befindet sich zu
diesem zeitpunkt auf seinem höhepunkt
bis zu 12.000 menschen zusammengepfercht
in viehwaggons werden täglich in das
konzentrationslager transportiert auf
der rampe findet die selektion statt
hier stehen die schergen der ss sie
trennen die familien frauen von ihren
männern mütter von ihren kindern ein
fingerzeig entscheidet über leben und
tod
die meisten menschen werden sofort in
die gaskammern geschickt am rande der
rampe der lagerarzt von auschwitz dr
josef mengele er interessiert sich
besonders für kinder und zwillinge die
er für seine barbarischen medizinischen
experimente aus sucht ihn erblickt in
die als erstes tage später wird sie ihn
wieder treffen und zum ersten mal seinen
namen hören wir sind im zug fast
gestorben
das war furchtbar der waggon hielt
plötzlich an wir wussten nicht wo wir
sind von außen haben wir deutsche
stimmen gemehrt
wir ahnten dass wir am zielort
angekommen sind
wir mussten schnell aussteigen und etwas
weiter entfernt von uns stand dr
[Musik]
die jungen und mädchen aus galanter
wurden sofort getrennt wir sind ein paar
schritte gegangen und haben plötzlich
gemerkt dass wir uns gar nicht von
unseren eltern und geschwistern
verabschiedet haben
wir drehten uns umschauten überall hin
wir sahen sie nicht mehr sie waren
einfach weg wie vom erdboden verschluckt
in die yeti und dori werden nicht
getrennt und können zunächst zusammen
bleiben
ihre eltern und brüder werden vermutlich
unmittelbar nach ihrer ankunft in den
gaskammern ermordet
die geschwister sollen mit 75 anderen
frauen aus galanter in block b gebracht
werden dem frauen lager von bergen doch
zunächst müssen sie in die sogenannte
sauna wochen später beschreibt schien
die in ihrem tagebuch die entwürdigende
prozedur einer der soldaten fängt an zu
reden
alle neu angekommenen werden
desinfiziert und erst dann untergebracht
und jetzt soll sich jeder ausziehen
zuerst werden eure haare abgeschnitten
unsere haare werden abgeschnitten
wir fragen nicht wir schwiegen
los zieht euch aus da ich mir auf und
wollten uns ausziehen aber im raum waren
auch männer dabei ihr habt den charme zu
hause gelassen
zieht euch endlich aus seiner aufseherin
wir ziehen uns aus
die männer laufen lachend im raum hin
und her
wir stehen nackt und rot vor scham herum
dann betritt lagerarzt dr josef mengele
den desinfektions raum
[Musik]
ich habe ihn gesehen als unsere haare
abgeschnitten worden sind er ist da
durchgegangen und schaute sich um
als man gerade dabei war doris haare
abzuschneiden ist er plötzlich stehen
geblieben und hat gesagt haare nicht
abschneiden
tory war sehr hübsch und gefiel am
offizier sehr sie gaben mir ein schönes
kleid mit zwei taschen
sie bekam auch zwei dicke buddha potter
sich doris taschen in ihrem kleid sah
steckte ich die zerknüllten
tagebuchblätter daran dass wir dann in
die baracke getrieben worden sind viele
mit ob die löcher in der wand auf später
versteckte ich die notizen in den
spalten
schließlich werden die geschwister
getrennt
die zwölfjährige dori wird von einer
aufseherin zu josef mengele geführt dort
bleibt sie für mehrere tage in die ihr
die und die anderen frauen ausgelernter
werden in block b 1 gebracht der
lageralltag ist unvorstellbar grausam
die gefangenen leiden hunger die meisten
sind krank und schutzlos der
sadistischen willkür der ss ausgeliefert
in der luft liegt ein stechender geruch
sie weckten uns ganz früh am morgen
sie haben die tür geöffnet wir haben
richtig gespürt das von draußen rauch
herein kam es auch furchtbar nach etwas
verbranntem irgendetwas wurde dort
verbrannt es war noch dunkel und wir
haben schlimme angst bekommen
wir dachten dass wir jetzt lebendig
verbrannt werden
wir wollten nicht vor die tür aber die
deutschen haben uns einfach mit
schlagstöcken heraus getrieben
ein mädchen fragte noch einen soldaten
was ist denn da draußen los so was ist
das für ein rauch er sagte einfach
jetzt werden eure eltern verbrannt drei
tage später wird dori von einer weiteren
zurück in das frauen lager gebracht
sie spricht nicht darüber was geschehen
ist dori ist erst zwölf und dürfte
eigentlich nicht im frauen blog sein
das wird ihr zum verhängnis ein wachmann
cerci aus der baracke
die aber die yeti nämlich mit lass mich
nicht alleine hier yeti ich hab hunger
sie war erst zwölf jahre alt und wir
ließen sie dort sonst hätte man uns doch
alle erschossen
dori blieb in auschwitz und sie starb
auch dort wir wissen nicht ob sie
verhungerte oder erfror
sie ist einfach gestorben im august 44
erreicht das kz lagerwesen seinen in
finalen höhepunkt über 700.000 menschen
wurden bis zu diesem zeitpunkt in
auschwitz-birkenau ermordet etwa eine
halbe million sollen noch folgen
alleine aus ungarn werden zwischen den
monaten mai und juni 438.000 juden nach
auschwitz birkenau deportiert
die meisten werden sofort in die
gaskammern getrieben
[Musik]
während in auschwitz und den anderen
vernichtungslagern weiter gemordet wird
rückt die ostfront richtung westen
trotz niederlagen gegen die rote armee
feiert die deutsche propaganda weiter
ihre kämpfer und die arbeiter in der
heimat
über die fahrten für den nachzug mit
männern und zwang den probierte nationen
hingegen werfen
da draußen die truppen kämpfen die vom
feld arbeitet die heimat in
unterschiedlichem einsatz für ihre
soldaten geschafft waffen und munition
und wieder waffen und munition
die rüstungsschmieden des dritten reichs
produzieren rund um die uhr um den
ertrag weiter steigern zu können
benötigt die wirtschaft menschlichen
nachschub millionen von kriegsgefangenen
und häftlingen aus den
konzentrationslagern werden den fabriken
als zwangsarbeiter eingesetzt
auch aus auschwitz birkenau fordert die
deutsche industrie immer mehr häftlinge
an
wer noch bei kräften ist soll in
sogenannten kriegs relevanten
unternehmen eingesetzt werden
die arbeitsbedingungen dort sind
menschenunwürdig
viele sterben am frühen morgen des 31
august müssen sich in die und die
anderen frauen im eiltempo vor ihrer
baracke aufstellen
ich nahm noch die tagebuchblätter an
mich ganz klein zerknüllt wir standen da
zu dritt meine schwester auf der einen
und ihre freundin auf der anderen seite
ich in der mitte dann kamen die
deutschen offiziere und wählten uns mit
75 mädchen zur arbeit aus kurze zeit
später verlassen schien die und die
anderen frauen auschwitz wieder
einem viehwaggon
die fahrt geht über breslau und endet
schließlich am bahnhof im
niederschlesischen reichenbach nahe
peters waldau dort hat die ss eine
sportschule in ein arbeitslager
umfunktioniert 2000 häftlinge sind hier
interniert darunter 800 frauen
die zwangsarbeiterinnen sind im
abgetrennten frauen lager in sechs
baracken untergebracht
es gibt keine heizungen geschlafen wird
auf blanken holztischen mit etwas strom
[Musik]
ein drei meter hoher elektrisch
geladener zaun umgibt das lager wer
flüchten will wird erschossen
cindy und ihre schwester hedy kommen in
eine baracke
in der nacht schlief ich ganz eng an
meiner schwester gekuschelt
wir versuchten uns gegenseitig
aufzuwärmen
es war so bitterkalt sie haben uns jeden
tag um 5 uhr oder halb fünf geweckt dann
mussten wir aufstehen
das war die größte strafe für uns jeden
morgen
wir haben nichts zu essen und zu trinken
bekommen bevor wir zur arbeit mussten
nicht gar nichts
oberhalb von peters waldauer betreibt
die rüstungsfirma karl diehl eine fabrik
für die produktion von kanaa zünden
hier werden 973 jüdische frauen aus
verschiedenen konzentrationslagern als
zwangsarbeiterinnen eingesetzt
es gibt nur wenig zu essen kaum wasser
die häftlinge sind den angriffen und
misshandlungen der aufseher schutzlos
ausgeliefert
[Musik]
inzwischen ist es dezember jeden morgen
müssen die und die anderen frauen zur
fabrik marschieren
fast eine stunde lang im gleichschritt
durch die eisige kälte der schnee vor an
unseren holzschuhe in einer dicken
schicht an
wir konnten kaum laufen das machte die
deutschen sehr wütend es ging ihnen zu
langsam alles aber wir konnten einfach
nicht schneller laufen
wir hatten doch nur holzschuhe an auf
dem weg zur arbeit mussten wir dann
deutsche lieder singen
sie handelten darüber wie großartig
deutschland ist und was für tolle dinge
es dort gibt
damit wir schneller gingen gab jemand
vorne den takt an
er sank vor wir mussten hinterher singen
in die steht in der fabrik an einer
werkbank 14 stunden täglich
sie baut dort sünder in granaten ein
jeder produktionsablauf wird penibel
dokumentiert
auf der vorderseite der sogenannten
laufkarten wann immer es geht nimmt sie
sich heimlich fehlerhaft ausgefüllte
zettel aus dem mülleimer und versteckt
sie unter ihrem kleid handy will ihre
notizen aus galanter und birkenau die
sie im lager unter ihrem bett aufbewahrt
hat auf die leeren ränge seiten
übertragen
ich merkte es mir gut was ich
geschrieben habe dass alles genau durch
und am nächsten tag bei der arbeit als
die deutschen aufseher frauen mal nicht
da waren übertrug sich schnell das
tagebuch auf die karten jeden tag nahm
ich ein blatt mit zurück ins lager gut
versteckt ich konnte es ja nicht in der
hand halten oder im beutel tragen
dort versteckte ich die blätter dann im
bett unter dem stroh ohne sie nochmals
durchzulesen
[Musik]
jeden tag beschreibt schien die unter
lebensgefahr die rückseiten der
laufkarten immer dann wenn die aufseher
die halle verlassen
insgesamt schafft sie 54 seiten hastig
und eng beschrieben
auf manchen karten malt sie sogar blumen
in der fantasie in flieht sie so einen
kurzen moment im täglichen horror die
alten zettel aus galanter und birkenau
schmeißt sie aus angst vor entdeckung in
die latrine
[Musik]
im lager und in der fabrik
verschlechtern sich die bedingungen für
die häftlinge von tag zu tag
viele sind krank unterernährt oder
einfach nur noch schwach wer keine kraft
mehr zum arbeiten hat wird ins 50
kilometer entfernt gelegene kz groß
rosen gebracht
auch die inzwischen 15 jährige cindy ist
am ende ihrer kräfte
sie und die anderen frauen müssen immer
öfter auch außerhalb der fabrik arbeiten
[Musik]
in der nacht mussten wir einen graben in
den feldern für die deutschen soldaten
anliegen
sie sagten uns das ist alles für den
fall dass der krieg und die front näher
kommen
nach dem nächtlichen graben mussten wir
tagsüber in der fabrik weiterarbeiten
wir haben nicht geschlafen keine sekunde
lang
ich glaube das war irgendwann im februar
wir haben die ganze nacht haben müssen
damit sich die deutschen soldaten
verstecken kann
der kampf im osten der ununterbrochene
angst haben und solche witzigen gegen
das auf die festung breslau scheint uns
immer wieder an den eigenen abwehr in
ihrer verteidiger männer und frauen
greifen mit zu um die stadt ständig
verteidigung freizuhalten
die front ist nur noch 50 kilometer von
peters waldau entfernt noch an cindy und
die häftlinge nichts vom baldigen
zusammenbruch des dritten reichs das
lager wird nur noch von wenigen soldaten
bewacht am 6 fällt die festung breslau
die wehrmacht kapituliert vor der roten
armee in derselben nacht werden die
frauen von den aufsehern ins freie
getrieben
sie sollen sofort nach peters waldau
aufbrechen nichts soll den russen in die
hände fallen
wir wussten nicht dass der krieg bald
vorbei sein wird
in der nacht mussten wir dann alle in
die fabrik marschieren und haben
sämtliche maschinen in den hallen
abmontiert und rausgebracht wir alle
geräte ins wasser werfen
als wir fertig waren stiegen die
deutschen in zwei große autos und fuhren
einfach weg sie ließen uns in der leeren
fabrik zurück
alles war jetzt ausgeräumt wir standen
dort rum und haben gewartet wird achten
dass die deutschen vielleicht wieder
zurückkommen es kam aber keiner mehr
dann sind wir einfach zurück ins lager
gegangen und haben gewartet
[Musik]
am 8 mai werden die häftlinge von peters
walldorf von der roten armee befreit in
die und ihre schwester hedy schlagen
sich über prag bis nach galanter durch
vom tragischen schicksal ihrer familie
wissen die geschwister noch nichts
die 54 tagebuchseiten versteckt schien
die sicher unter ihrem kleid jerusalem
74 jahre nach ende des zweiten
weltkrieges
hier hat schon die ihre neue heimat
gefunden und eine eigene familie
gegründet 1949 siedelte sie frisch
vermählt mit ehemann emil müller von
galanter nach israel
im gleichen jahr bekam schien die ihr
erstes kind
es war ein mädchen sie nannte es dori
ihr sohn isaak viel mit 20 als soldat im
jom-kippur-krieg ehemann emil starb 2006
ihr jüngster sohn ariel ist heute 62
schön die selbst sagt sie habe später
ein schönes leben gehabt
jetzt habe ich das tagebuch
und wenn wir nicht über diese zeit reden
dann schwinden die erinnerungen
bald werde ich sterben und ich will
nicht dass man die menschen vergisst die
alle ermordet worden sind
es wäre ein schlimmes gefühl dass die
erinnerungen an jene für immer
ausgelöscht werden
die sonne scheint durch das fenster rein
streichelt mein gesicht
als hätte sie mich nur aus einem tiefen
traum wecken wollen ich schaue mich um
und sehe die vier gefängnis länder die
mich an die schreckliche wahrheit
[Musik]